Because most of what we know about the Trojan War comes from stories...
...told to entertain people, we cannot be sure that it is true.
Sometimes a storyteller would add things to the stories to make them more exciting.
Sometimes, because the stories were being passed along by word of mouth,...
...things got mixed up and the story was changed.
However, we know the city of Troy did exist.
In the 1870s a famous archeologist named Henry Schliemann found the ruins.
Since then, many archeologists have searched there.
There is evidence of some fighting and of a fire at about the right time.
Because we have no written records, we cannot be sure about the details.
We will never know whether Helen and Paris ever really lived.
What do you think?